when you do a sport like boxing it is
intense like you going into a fight
you're going into a war you're going in
to something where you can come out hurt
you can come out on the other side he
realized the stakes of that fire and he
definitely realizes the states of this
class when no one's punching at you and
you have a lot before and they letting
you hit them your natural instinct is to
keep whacking them so I had to make it
love her no calm down the jab just relax
relax relax
one of the things I've being us to ask
you about more than anything
yeah is what happened with dead sheep oh
yeah yeah he's speed power ahead
movement natural ability is literally
better than Jay Jay in my opinion I've
got the exposure that a lot of people
strive really hard to get managed to
acquire it through a different angle now
it's my job to make sure that all of
this talk and all of this positive
praise that I get just ends up being
here you go I fulfilled when you said I
was gonna be which is a future world
champion this week a man who needs no
introduction
cast Badal Riley ksi straight out aka
potentially a future world champion gold
medalist potentially in there no no any
more silver medal didn't you see I was
listening and bronze
so you're basically the star saw of the
ksi documentary can't lose a lot of
people felt like you stole the show a
little bit no I feel like it was just
you know when some things new you is get
more credit for it once it becomes
normal that he is used to being in the
spotlight
they want to see JJ so when he's there's
like okay cool were used to seeing you
do your thing Oh
someone else is here that's what a
person I know it's know you're playing
it done but I remember from the day I
met you which was the jaw while I press
conference yeah
yeah absolutely and I didn't know what
expect he'll had history and as you juju
had you obviously yeah yeah and when we
sat down to talk onstage I became very
aware very quickly that you were capable
of talking off the cuff yeah George
trainers were like nowhere near what you
were terms of personality so it was sort
of obvious then I was like I mean if
this guy can box you need to have a
better personality you know it's all
good having skills but if no one wants
to watch and no one cares then what does
it play it came across very weird on
that day there didn't it because
obviously to a lot of people at that
time no one really had seen you training
with Jay they knew you were training me
JJ yeah yeah yeah it came across because
no one had seen Jay Jay box right or
anyone no one you really knew about Joe
or anyone else you guys were so laid
back watching that back in the movie
like yeah because it was confident yeah
when you know what you're doing and you
know the work you put in you don't need
to get a higher power by it but yeah you
know and the thing is I told Jay Jay
from day one I said okay looking at Joe
watching his last fight it's gonna come
at you so what we're gonna do is just
saw a camp that allows you to move use
your jab keep him away from you and when
he gets a bit tired be him so we had
that game plan from day one and you can
hear in the documentary on that he's
gonna be fit you're not gonna get tired
he's gonna pressure you when people are
running at you do this this this and
this so when it came to the press
conference and they were all tense it
just fought yet he's just gonna play
right into our gameplan and it just made
us calm what he thinks about YouTube
tension though because it's not the same
as I've never been to a boxing press
conference yes yeah but doesn't feel the
same when I learned 14 year olds and
nervous as opposed to a roomful of
actual yeah is this boxing press
conference obviously the demographic age
it's a lot higher so everyone's a bit
more mature and less emotionally there's
a lot of emotion in that room yeah
yeah everyone's neutral like a pro
boxing press conference like I'm a fan
of this person I'm not a fan of you I
want you to win I'm not useful I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna insult your money so
everyone and I hope it gets in your head
right and it is hectic up there and
sometimes you just need to lay back and
literally just let them do their thing
because if you try and it just gets one
message dancing it going back to that
press conference yeah it was chalk and
cheese the way you were like so I'm
asking you one play what what's Gigi's
biggest strength than you and everything
like you know play in the right game
plan yeah - because you could see Joe
and his trainers were a lot more
stressed out than what you they were
very tense and very tense like I could
see the body language of them were we're
gonna go out there we're gonna be
serious we're gonna have a straight face
stone face and try and intimidate people
by being a serious like free serious guy
sitting at the table not mucking about
but it done the complete opposite in my
opinion and when you come out and you're
sitting there and you're holding
yourself like this looking down and just
looking angry it's just I don't need to
do that mmm the main thing that sort of
blows my mind about you in the training
and everything I watched in the car
loose dark how mature you are for age
allows me [__] mate to be honest
because like JJ's all are than you yeah
and really comes like you're his big
brother because you've obviously grown
up fast in and doing the boxer than that
is there anything else that's
contributed to you being wise beyond
years I just think in terms of boxing
I've been doing it for so many years
I've been in like 15 years so I guess
anyone that does anything for that
period of time you're gonna be extremely
confident you're gonna be outspoken and
what your
because you know you have everything to
back it up and also always I'm always
hanging around people over didn't mean
my parents didn't baby me that day from
I was growing up they just taught me
well you've been boxing since five I
won't really baby that I was just Taurus
Ponce ability morals hard work from a
young age so now I'm still at a young
age I've managed to work myself into a
good position so later on in life I can
just chill back and be immature as I
worked yeah so when I look at boxing is
of years of business it seems like the
ones who click on the soonest that this
is show business as much as it is a
sport you want to make the most money in
other one is accessible and it feels
like your interaction with Jay Jay yo
you're gonna learn a lot about the
entertainment side of it and now you can
almost join the sales that you've got
with the showmanship of JJ and it's
giving me exposure to a lot of Pro boxes
that have never had a lot of Pro boxes
haven't had half the exposure to have
managed to get base of training JJ so it
is excellent fighters out there very
skillful fighters but you put them in
front of a camera they can't talk you
get an interview you get minimal words
out of them and everyone just havin
kereama and being around JJ and being
around all the other guys as well not
just to mention Joe chill out obviously
our train car frizzy calyx and these
fibers like fights Oh guys that have big
personalities and being around those
guys you know it pays off because then
you just feed off them yeah so I want to
talk about obviously your career and
where you're wanting to go but I think a
lot of people will want to know a lot
about like what's coming up to this big
fighting so the story so far so good
can we sort of go back to when you first
met Jay Jay like yeah have you seen
videos of him before you met he I've
seen a few videos I've got a few family
members that are strong fans of him so
I've seen the videos but I never I was
never a gun at watched his his stuff no
what was your impression of
a couple of the videos and when you
first met him like what was going
through your head without thinking I
think because I already trained a lot of
his friends before me in him when I met
him it was kind of like oh this was
bound to happen
type thing but was it such a closed
circle YouTube community so small
oh okay if I trained you you you and you
and your old friends with JJ at some
point I'll meet him to what level I
don't know but I knew at some point I'd
bump into him and we would talk and
whatnot and essentially because of kelex
why as I trained in JJ because the whole
thing happened with Weller upload event
KJ was trained in boxing with someone
else and then callek said to him I PT is
a box I mean he's good like he trusts me
he's got good credentials by it and I
got a random photo from JJ one day on
Twitter but he didn't say anything so it
was just a random follows okay cause
it's kind of shameful he said you
probably get in touch with you soon or
not so he came down to the gym where I
trained all the guys done one session I
mean it might lack a little spa he was
like okay cool he said he's good he's
good all the other guys were giving me
with a you know information I needed and
everything and then he said yeah just
just get to work let's do some sessions
and then there was no these sessions I
seen some footage where I give was
pressurize in the minis he look like a
bag of shite the beef blessed of I mean
obviously come on some way so we can say
that now but of course there I think
he's always had that power in his hands
and whatever but it feels like throwing
punches is one thing but being able to
take them as a whole new thing I think
everyone can punch anyone confronts
taking punches takes some learning yeah
some discipline yeah throwing punches is
easy but when he from the moment he hit
the pads first time I said okay his
heart he was naturally quick and he hit
hard so I thought this doesn't need to
be our focus focusing on speed and power
no everything needs to be you know
technique and actually making the speed
in power and the technique all come into
one but he's always had a flake ability
in terms of punch power punch speed yeah
that was quite funny though because the
he made his name sitting on the couch
playing on 50 yeah it's a vania building
tellers you see Joe first thing jaws
psycho jaws gym rat he loves the gym and
he said I'm gonna show you what an
athlete is Logan saying similar things
and you're saying they may underestimate
judges yeah obviously Logan's an athlete
we know he's wrestled wrestling is not
easy
therefore it's not let's not play it
down you know wrestling is a hard spoon
never tried it but you don't need to get
shot to Maya hurts it's one of those
things yeah but at the same time it
doesn't mean someone can't start
something and become better in that
field if it was a wrestling match here
JJ's getting handled it's a boxing match
he's box for long why he's learning more
advanced things that Logan has to catch
up and learn if he wants to make this
flat compared that's just a timing thing
you know he started before it so he's
learning more advanced things now and
that is why as much as the fight is
competitive JJ takes the victory he's
got heart he didn't have to really show
you against Joe but I've seen up women
hearts were seen there was a big
muscular dude was that you but I didn't
realize like you decisive but next to JJ
you look like a monster villain you you
are the moat like that was a good shot
to get Ali onion because he doesn't wear
take kickboxing oh I heard about that
yeah by he's predominantly good with his
hands
so I said and I said dolly and I'm I
needed to get a couple rounds in with JJ
then he was like that what do you mean
was that on him when he goes lips all
right
then he said all right got the gloves on
and then you saw that the footage but
that was for me to test JJ some people
might think I was being evil or whatnot
but it was to see can you deal with the
flip flip side of boxing because boxing
is
Landen shortest bites in a way looking
pretty sometimes you're gonna get
clocked with hard punches can you take
those punches and that's why I flew him
in there with Leon I could put him in
there with me but their fears are really
day I'm his coach so if he's never gonna
really respond to me the same he didn't
know Leon as well at the time summer
gets on my random face bigger guy scary
guy hit you
did you drop on the floor a couple of
times you got back up I said yeah you
can box you that's cool you're tough
enough that was the test because that
was actually quite a funny scene to
watch but I imagine I mean for us from
the outside being like yeah that's
hilarious
I'm MBK that was reactions are quite
comedic like he's like a [__] knock
me out like that is hilarious it's
really well looked at me off-camera like
to see if there's any time I'm gonna get
rid of you
there's no college yesterday yeah today
I might made that decision that you
actually don't have my best interest at
heart but you know it'll play doh or it
then what really struck me about the
documentary is the relationship between
you two because again it's sort of
interesting to see I think a lot of
people think of trainers in the same way
as they think of Rocky's trainer you
know I can old guys no god bless not
subservient but a little bit more
experienced but he's not physically got
it anymore and like you know he's it's
different
well not every box um it's a bit like
footballers not every good footballer
makes a good manager not every boxer can
be of course anything yeah and we see
that with modern-day football managers
as well like Bobby Robson Jose Mourinho
Rafa Benitez all these guys are clever
outside the ring but that's like that's
become a bit of a stereotype of people
who've gone to the side your
relationship with him is a little bit
different and I thought I think it's
really interesting to see the way that
you build him up the way that you are
the way that you're helping him without
being like um you know I'm lower than
you you two are on a very similar level
yes our relationship goes hand-in-hand
you know he owns me and aspects of my
life that I couldn't help myself
right and that's in all honesty you know
he's done things I mean that you know I
have to always say I'm mad appreciative
for and vice-versa like he needed the
skills in order to get in the position
he's in I needed the exposure and
you know the experience of all the other
side of things besides boxing you know
how to social media presence and how to
handle other things so we literally
bounce off each other perfectly and I
feel like when you do a sport like
boxing it is intense like you going into
a fight you're going into a war you're
going in to something where you can come
out of her you can come out on the other
side so when you walk into the ring with
those people behind you if you don't
trust in at least one person is missing
in that that you don't trust you're
gonna feel it you use that energy you
can feel it you need to walk to the ring
and know okay what he says I can listen
100% and not doubt it you don't want to
have a coach and go oh yeah I think you
should jump when you're thinking your
head should I ain't good when you were
when you were coming out of the ring and
the boos whirring an out you can hear
your voice clearly going yeah that's
what we want that's your name is hey we
need that because I eat for someone he's
obviously done lots in his life he's at
you've created but he's never box before
you never been in the arena that
probably booing him before he's always
everyone's hero JJ is them is the man
most of time so walking out and hearing
booing I had to just lame they look less
calm we weren't that we weren't and at
the end of the fight you see in the
documentary they make what so much on
that mic yeah I said to him they're not
doing now mmm that's why that Buddha
[__] doesn't matter because they're not
doing anymore
and then he was like yeah that's true
that's why now we don't take in all of
that we don't taking all that stuff and
I think it said a lot at that press
conference most recently with Logan when
he was getting that negative firing
firing firing and then he said no I
ain't gonna have this he must be the
cool kid ya going on that a second cuz I
was you were going too fast for a little
bit [__] you are there you've obviously
psychoanalyzed the way joella's crew
handled it last time what did you make
of both press conferences this time I
feel and be completely honest with you
it was good the the last press
conference with Logan the most recent
one it was a good press conference I'm
gonna hit some sit down I wanted some
questions if I'm honest me too no no I
feel like I feel like just as it was
about to stop the onslaught was about to
stop he left I think literally a minute
more you would have got them to sit down
and we would have had some table and
some questions from our perspective is
great
at the end of the day we managed to
handle the L a press conference way bed
and they handled the UK one Jake hand
away well in my opinion for what he
could do I agree off I actually come up
with a yeah a lot of respect for chair
yeah well Jake walked out on that stage
even stood behind Jake that was the
first wave of here yeah I'm from the
crazy my food [__] hell and he just
walked out like it was nothing like and
I did respect that there wasn't much he
could do but he'd only he done we could
do then give him credit for that
obviously Logan took the approach of
I've come to sit down and answer some
questions we're not gonna do like a WWE
type thing which is which was his
approach but at the end of the day we
went away we took our one more chance we
took all the backlash so it was our time
to let some steam off and just before
that will ended he left so there's a
unusual situation for him to go into
because actually I feel like also the
press conference in LA didn't feel that
many of those punches landed on JJ like
shouting Walmart JJ's just there like
cool yes what I doesn't matter
buddies what is warm-up the one thing I
picked up from this the press
conferences personally was to [__] that
Logan was the one to lose his cool first
on both occasions he was the one who put
his hands as changing the first time yes
and he was the one who stormed off the
second time and if and this isn't me
having a pot because I am staying
neutral of no you don't like that but if
you're gonna be good in the ring you
always have to try and keep your cool I
never had long as possible
hundred percent now after we a fool you
know this is not digging anyone now it's
just speaking facts and what's been
shown he has lost his cool twice and
that's one of those things that you
can't get rid of overnight
I think that's JJ's biggest strength of
my opinion when people look and he has
the ability to say very calm himself and
that makes him a dangerous opponent so
readability is enclosed too once I can
get in joella's head he got in joella's
head and remain calm after the push
situation you remain calm and after
return is secured see what the guys
invited me to go because I said I've
been trained in turns over well so they
said how you want to come on upload this
in to my hotel so I was like yeah it's
good fun everyone was just doing this
but but the thing is so Joe Rogan
describes fighting as I think it's
critical thinking with dire consequences
and the more calm you are within that
moment about her decision maker and
you're going to have and I think that's
why I after the press conference I just
thought myself Logan definitely has a
temper on him and yet and JJ I'm always
astounded at how calm he is and all the
mayhem like when he come up all those
boos and he just seemed so calm I sort
of surprised as like one thing I think
is important as well is he really got
into his dad and his dad lost his cool
and that's not me taking a shot at him I
don't know I don't really know him much
about their family but it must be
difficult because Logan must be thinking
listen I can take a load of shots yeah
yeah yeah respect myself in other
people's shoes you know it's a hard
thing to do as humans we live from our
view so taking yourself as a hard thing
but take yourself and that's it there
and I think okay I'm Logan crowds do
saying all this stuff to me insulting my
family calling my girlfriend a hole and
wear these things it's gonna get to me I
would I would have started twitching
under the table but I think in that in
that moment I would have nothing lost
forever but I wouldn't have gone on for
then the actual questions when they came
out with finger with a sat down board up
and then went okay questions Judy what
you got boy boss it strike me there was
no one on that side or on Logan's team
who was doing there
don't worry about the booing thing like
no one was you know the way you've got
in the churches yeah yeah straight
didn't feel like the whole team we use
in the stage weren't you yes you could
have had a bit more support from his
team to be like yeah we got this we got
this I mean within our camp within our
camp for all the fighters that are
trained we got a bond we all got a bun
beyond boxing if JJ never put gloves on
again I'd still go 2,000 cm just lovely
happened with the other guys that train
everyone else is fine there is abundant
outside of the ring so when people are
booing I'm not I'm not just saying it as
a coach I'm saying as a friend listen I
get that yeah don't take in this stuff
you don't need to take this in somebody
didn't seem like he had that and also if
I was as I was watching the press
conference across the stage looking at
all of his camp yeah he had the Welsh
guy the one who's the prankster he had
Briggs he had his dad I think Jake would
joke was that for a little while and
then step back there were loads of
people all of them were just stood there
going what was going it was it was
anyone would have been shell-shocked
yeah it was comical can we go back to
the - oh well a fight yeah of course um
when I watched the documentary the
advice you gave JJ and the way you spoke
so calmly or men like you you just
seemed so confident at that moment now
how do you decide what you're going to
say in between rounds I go work small
window to make sure what you're saying
this is this is where the experience
comes in
I could watch box in me I could sit down
me I could sit down with my dad would
sit down with Leon watch boxing what two
minutes over around and be like he's
going to lose because you can just see
there's certain signs there's certain
body languages behaviours how the person
that being maneuvered just right there
every level then amateur all the way up
to window watching say drop
how much a financing he's gonna lose
this right I can watch AJ and be like oh
he's gonna be hit so long that he ain't
stopping him early right you can just
tell and when you're watching the lower
the level the easier is to dissect the
iPoker in a sense yeah so if I'm
watching if I'm watching a pro fight it
might take me longer to say whoa I don't
know about this one watching Jay Jay box
watching Joe box I can literally go 40
seconds you need to do this more you
need to do that more if he does this
that will work because the level how
advanced the boxing is I can just work
it out quick what was going through your
head yeah because I was a bit closer to
Jordan I was to judge you before the
fight so ugly I mean I could have made
that more obvious during the fight when
your comes out it isn't throwing yeah
what were you thinking um my initial
thought was he was trying to tie a JJ
out which was what you said after the
fight that is my genuine I said I was in
the corner I looked at Leona I said he's
gonna punch himself out he's gonna punch
himself out because they say that like
what scene is it takes it you need to do
it to really know how it feels to like
to be in a certain situation so when no
one's punching at you and you haven't
watched before and they letting you hit
them your natural instinct is to keep
whacking them
you don't think okay take a bit of time
off just put my jab out and see you just
go go three four so I had to make it now
that no calm down the jab just relax
relax relax turns out you didn't punch
really anyway but just in case we had to
have him to save his energy because he I
was honestly thinking he's gonna make
him wear him down wear him down wear him
down and then get him in like around
four or five right yeah I think when one
thing I did pick up anywhere from
watching some of the sparring sessions
that Joe had is he wasn't as naturally
gifted as JJ yeah it happens anyway yeah
but I did feel like the caution that JJ
was getting was much higher of a level
than what I seen Joe getting like some
of the sparring sessions Joe got when I
watched his documentary I was like wow
yeah what's there I watched it in Vegas
and Vegas I was I watched it there and I
looked in and I said that did the
trainer's on a vocal
with when you watch can't lose I'm
soaking every every scene JJ do this you
need to do this more if it isn't that
when use watch enjoys doc it was like
his coaches are just on the side no
words they felt like they were trying to
beast him into a boy it was kind of like
okay you're watching him he's getting
him some punches repeatedly are you
gonna tell him to give hands up we're
just gonna wait and end it around and
wet blood from his nose yeah you need to
help we are there to coach him he hasn't
box before he needs the extra direction
I'll give Joe credit the Lord Scott
tough and I said then in the post-fight
interview when you asked me as well I
said he's tough yeah because he's going
highest rated natural no you train hard
he train really hard 100% we know he
train hard that's why I pushed Jay Jay
as hard as I did I knew he was gonna
graft
he took some punches in there that for
someone hasn't box before I had the one
fight before
that takes I'm doing I've seen people
drop from less and for him to go in
there and take the punches that he did
and even when he was he would have kept
going but he didn't fool we didn't drop
on the floor it was coming but yes come
in but we can talk on what could have
happened but what actually happened he
firm credit to him and me and Joe has
spoken since and um he will tell you
I've given him the utmost respect when
it comes to Logan fight has organized
the sparring session with Joe that's
about to happen this week yeah what do
you make of that maneuver the only way
that becomes relevant in any way is if
Logan dispatches Joe inspiron with sheer
ease and just says look one punch bang
there you go that's how I would have
dealt with Joe's friend they're not
known to be friends or even associated
with each other the only reason why he'd
be used enjoyed because Joe's the only
person to box Jay Jay and it's a good
way of saying okay it took you three
rounds happy when I asked
I can do him like this that's the only
reason it's not to help him out or give
him any publicity or anything like that
it's simply to me JJ look bad and say I
can one bit you which is pretty empty
anyway because JJ's also changed as a
fighter since there is he this is what
you have to realize he's not fighting
Joe Willis or whatever he does to Joe a
lot credit to him but stars me at fights
it doesn't matter there's people Doug it
really doesn't know how he gets rid of
Joker right he's not fine my jaw opened
admits he's been on holiday since that
vibe it hasn't touched a glob since that
injury you're not you're not actually
fighting the jaw that pjj for yeah
exactly only my brain that's rusty Oh
rusty you're talking about someone
appeared on a beach for three months and
all but I did think I didn't message Joe
be honest now when because I thought we
had JJ was too big from and and logins
bigger than JJ I just meant just keep
your [__] hands up yeah cuz they're
rich they're not kids gonna have on you
it's gonna be his see this is everything
I think Joe is gonna don't go hard we
know you got he's not gonna go in there
lay down he's gonna go in and do what
you can do and whatever happens happens
but um yeah I'm not surprised Logan's
doing this lie he's in the country he
wants to get things piping up a bit more
let's let's say I'm gonna spoil a winner
and get the whole internet Graham crazy
that's what he's good at how much you
pay attention to that campsite that like
their camp because either this is a
thing that is the worst thing you can do
right paying attention to other people's
camp is a sure way to forget about yours
we got we know what we need to be doing
they're gonna do it at Durham regardless
of who were watching or not it doesn't
matter we've seen the little TMZ footage
of his born that could easily be
obviously he probably gave it to him
because how comes nothing else has ever
been released it's just that smart and
so you gave him a little something and
so when a pinch of salt really I need to
make sure JJ is in the best condition if
JJ's in the best condition he wins when
I fight if I'm in the best condition I
win I don't need to worry about it when
you are not so doing and I take that
same philosophy one's also going to do
help and you're in a really
a bit of a disadvantage because you have
not got anything on Logan
other than the fact that you know how
he's built and you know he's pretty
tough lately
yeah yeah although I'm sure that you've
got the experience no now roughly how
those kind of guys would come out
naturally anyway yeah but the thing is
that disadvantage as well because
sometimes it's worse to have
preconceived ideas and no ideas at all
you know when you go into something
expecting and think you know this is
gonna happen or this is his weakness and
then the witness a in there it can set
you back just then you went in the other
empty mind hmm
so I feel like Logan's at the
disadvantage to the plane I it seems
that JJ's at disappoints because this
footage for him to watch what if there's
improvements made the footage becomes
weight and that's my that's my goal in
this campus to make that footage and the
next footage look completely different
JJ has you and we've already established
that Logan I don't know who the fog was
true yeah but what I was going more down
the route of just positive because one
thing that really struck me as well
about the first fight we're sort of
skipping all over the place here but
about the first fight was that if JJ's
training with you you naturally pick up
body language you pick up movements
you'll be watching other people fighting
I feel like Jo was holding it it's not
criticism a job I didn't feel like Jo
was holding himself in the same way that
JJ was the transformation that JJ went
through physically he looked like he was
carrying himself as a different person
yeah that and what's interesting is I
want to know how you got to the point
where you are now like who was the
person who got you to this point
so my dad told me add two books when I
was six he said well when even when I
was two he just used to mock us about
Miss about when was he a boxer yeah you
say you know got to any sort of level
that's that recognizable but he just
done it enough to learn the sport and
say when I have a son you're gonna get
to where you can get to based off my
knowledge so yeah I used to just maka
Bob I went to the boxing gym when I was
six
what was that also I used to what what
the first box injury yeah that's ripped
in boxing club side that's in Bethnal
Green all right not even too far
but um started off there done a bear box
in and I've always trained a lot at home
I was never a person to rely on the
coaches in the gym I was fortunate
enough to have my dad there when you're
in amateur boxing club there's over 30
kids in the your trainer can only tell
you so much and they prioritize the time
for the people that they think win
national championships and etc so if you
want you not got that extra person there
you just end up on the wayside so I was
lucky I had my daddy used to just guide
me through guide me through teaching
parts of the school watch boxing
practice practice practice and then and
this is all gone to here no and it's
that same is it the same in the way that
you're speaking to JJ because it strikes
me that like there are Premier League
managers you don't seem to be able to
motivate people
I mean Gareth Southgate definitely
doesn't seem to be able to motivate
anyone in a way that you see
personalities it's personalities I feel
like that trend
oh my train people that I can't connect
with mm-hmm they don't take to my style
of training it's too hard it's a bit too
hard I might I get frustrated a bit too
easy on them I'm not perfect train on no
way but for JJ I'm perfect because his
temperament and my temperament they're
taking a walk across yeah that day we
Joe together there's people I trained
that they just can't get to grips with
how I do things because I'm not sure you
can see him watch you're going up in it
like oh I'll be a lot of amateur boxing
nice yeah Newcastle knock yeah you see
you're like I mean if I have you up
there like these these eight-year-olds
and like [__] them just like I mean
like [__] oh good mentality from a
young age I've got installed with a
fight in mentality discipline of what's
right what's wrong what needs to be done
compared to what you want to do you know
as I lose a fine line between what you
want to do and what needs to be done so
JJ might not want to spar with Leon for
example but it needed to be done and
that is the line that I work in what
needs to be not what he wants to do is
he spoke with Leon sense no he doesn't
need to know he knows
you will know same the same right okay
subconsciously little million tune the
scene okay yeah so that's bad the moment
in Vegas where you're in Mayweather gym
yeah Logan walks in the door yeah can
you describe what that was like for us
it was a lot of rumors going around
there's a little bit of it was a bit
tight in those like Logan's gonna turn
up at the gym you know type at the gym
um we got remember primarily I'm a boxer
so I'm in the me with a gym I'm thinking
about boxing I'm not Logan's the last of
my Forte's I'm just thinking I'm in the
middle of a gym I'm about to wrap my
hands I'm about to get on a heavy bag
and do some work
and then I just hear yeah okay my turn
Logan that turn up boom walks in the gym
and then there's people in there that
don't know who JJ and Logan are so they
just thinking who's this guy that's just
walked into the gym and the whole gym
stopped and surround him what's going on
so there's the whole gym literally
stopped saw those guys going I having a
confrontation
what do you think Logan because
size-wise you're obviously gonna be more
aware of like how big JJ is completely
got high on him he's got high on him
he's a he's a bigger person he's just
actually it was except since Vegas he's
lost a lot of weight he is just a little
ways agreement you know and there isn't
there isn't by I rough guess that Logan
will come in around 90 92 kilos roughly
that's what I guess
JJ was 83 so he wasn't done he's put on
weight but this is one thing everyone
gets too caught up on weight right they
get to co-op and weight when you're
within a certain bracket if you if
you're more skillful you can you you can
take the person out weight isn't as big
a deal as everyone makes it at the other
day is not judge enough I knew if he was
fighting you you could be a school for
as you want
one club up one down very luckily for
that yeah but the weight difference is
not that drastic so we're not trying to
focus on a ha okay even overnight let's
be naive as well just be 92 with him no
because this rock doesn't not
yeah I was gonna I wasn't I was gonna
say that I feel like well Oh was him
would have been in better shape to fat
JJ when you were at the upload press
conference if you stayed around that way
he would have been able to perform
better I feel like he spent so much time
getting the size that it's like to
hinder his speed I was thinking from my
point of view before the fight I was
like if I'm if I'm well I would want to
be lean and quick yeah around that ring
and be hard to pin down like Pacquiao
style that might be why Logan has lost
weight because he might be thinking the
same thing I'm not gonna I'm not
wrestling I'm gonna be a box I need to
be a nun I need to be nimble so this is
good it's very exciting line only these
things are afraid people would think oh
is it afraid you know makes it great it
makes it even better we win that's
always my mentality I don't look at it
he's nice to me so it's gonna be hard
know this it's gonna be like okay he got
in shape yeah he's got abs and we still
talking about that doesn't that's the
mentality that's the way to look it this
is what we bring this is the energy we
bring into the cam there's no negativity
there's no uh yeah he's biceps bigger
than your so you know nah doesn't know
what's the training camp being like then
for Logan because it does it does feel
like JJ is in more danger than he was
last time for a potential yeah he is so
he is he is in more danger this is why
that's why it's a bigger fight yeah if
he was fighting someone that was the
same possess the same dangerous Joe how
many of us would be interested well yeah
cuz I looked at I interviewed a judge
just before the fight and Jada was like
more confident than Conor McGregor going
into this I remember coming away me and
him or on the train and I was like I've
never known anyone so confident before
fighting me so difficult yeah absolutely
sure he's gonna win I felt obviously it
was right seeing him in real life really
changed what the way that I felt about
the whole situation because that we both
would seem Joe and the temperament of
Joe at that point and we'd seen JJ and
the temperament of JJ always talking
very well before the photo is love I
think Joe like credit to Joe again like
he really Joe did what Joe could do in
that time and also what all these things
but JJ
was just another level when we walked
out that house it was crazy I was
thinking to myself like if he there's a
danger in winning against jaws that you
gain confidence that you can just do
that and then when you take on someone
as big and strong as Logan who was as
fit as Logan is if you're coming with
that same mentality exact you need to
give him more respect yeah that's
exactly true what you said is right
that's why for this camp we've had
aspiring partners we got specific
sparring partners with different styles
and experience as people in that JJ's
was that can he he won't get the better
of or you really will struggle to get
the better because their experience and
they box and that is all because of what
you just said
he's not Joella the same way Logan can
say I'm not sure that you're right
you're not sure so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna adjust when I make things
harder for JJ put JJ in situations in
camp that he was an infinite Jo camp so
when we do fight he can possess the same
confidence because the the workload has
adjusted with the opponent so his
confidence can just match and stay where
it was not same camp different guy okay
yeah it's gonna be that Jo and getting
laid into North yeah I just did it yeah
after watching the first fight obviously
really impressed with the output like I
think exact same night there was a there
was another box and fight on with JJ
actually landed more punches Gees then
and yeah and I will submit I remember
billion in the third round and thinking
he's just not slowing down like the
engine on him was really impressive but
if there was a weakness and I'm I don't
think I'm seeing anything that nobody
doesn't know buddy he was hands down
chin available again you had an adductor
anything on this like they say they
asked me was JJ's witness and I said his
defense and that was me being honest and
it's not this is what honesty is about
everyone can see the truth
some people speaking and some people
choose to avoid it I can see his defense
is bad Logan can see the defense is bad
you don't take rocky aside to work it
out what my job is is to make these
things I'm if change that and that's
what this whole car has been about
improving it
offense improving these overall books
and ability so that these things become
hearsay it's gonna be an aggressive
fight like a very interesting very what
I want to count lose last night I was
like really looking for this know one
thing that did struck me about it was
obviously saw had JJ felt on that night
how are you feeling because obviously
there was a you were quite contrast at
one point you're quite playful when
you're getting him ready for the fight
and then the next second you're light
but you're mentally ready Oh yet another
night at a job this how I am so in the
change room there's music on we've got
rain water spray water and we're happy
and everything's jolly once you get in
the gloves are on you step through the
ropes that's it you gotta be willing to
go to war and your corner have to be the
same economy let he can't go in there
Joe hit any big shots and I'm just jolly
you all on the side no it's serious and
as soon as he won and as soon as we were
patterning we jump around and was early
again you are known to switch it on
switch it off so I did float between the
two because you don't need me in the
changing room as your coach you got to
have a biggest night of your life and
I'm just poking around stressed out
stressed out miss Dunphy's you're gonna
the guy you look to for confidence and
that motivation on the night is is like
this you're gonna bring or maybe I
should feel like this to kiss his
demeanor changed it very very visibly in
the documentary I don't to give away
everything you probably stop to watch it
but by it changes quite a lot it is it
is a really good documentary I think
this is crazy man what after probably
managed to do is though that you he was
he completely changed on that day like
he was very quiet and very introverted
how when you saw his calyx and those
guys were sort of making fun of him a
little bit like their videos I wasn't
with him earlier in the day yeah so we
was maintaining contact obviously
through text someone are just asking how
you feeling you know big day how you
feeling news that yeah I'm good in you
you know JJ's always that yeah I'm good
I'm good I'm good you have to know him
to dig they can fight us through what
before the Guam yes some people don't
know how to handle it
prick I expect him to go quiet I'm the
same about night the day before maybe
even in the week before I started to get
a bit into my zone where I'm not as
sociable I start to you know just watch
box in and just go into my own little
zone but I feel like that's needed it's
good it's good for focus it's good to
realize the stakes of things so you
don't take it from right he realized the
stakes of that fight and he definitely
realizes the states of this class that
this is the wonder right it's this I
would advocate for as pride when I get
in the ring it's a pride thing that you
don't want someone else to say walk
around saying I got the better of you I
beat you every time you look at that
person they can say I won you're below
me it's a pride thing you know in your
career how did you because obviously
you've probably over 150 amateur fights
yeah so that isn't that many yeah it's
not too bad you know
did you I don't know how many you lost
but what yeah so I had 50 fights and a
141 so I lost no I lost 9 fight how did
you deal with the fear the first defeats
the hardest when was that went by I was
15 no at the time and I started taking
things oh go ahead
you know I'm young I was like Phooey I'm
just like you know I just bought some
things free to know you know this is
pretty too so I wanted one few national
titles at that point and everyone's
singing my praises and I'm just like is
this pretty true and then a funny thing
is my dad the guy that I was fighting he
was a national champion he's from Wales
and he was a national champion and we
have like the Great Britain tournament
and I wanted a year before so I was out
of course I'm gonna win again just rock
hard
back to back yeah we're all caught back
to back and were winless and then my dad
said you gotta be careful this guy
because he has the style that you seem
to not know how to deal with right now
so you need to make sure you focus early
know
who did stuff that a dad would tell you
then I went in there Astro was just like
us and he beat me time it was a points
decision right I lost a clearly lost
didn't get battered by declare lose the
file it is not hard to work I lost the
fight and from that point it burns that
was my first time okay I'm not I'm not
invincible
I can be beaten and it's a hard feeling
because you're like I fought that what's
gonna piss it and then some guys walking
around and you stand on the podium and
his podium just a little bit higher than
yours mid was a different color you can
look down there you shake and say well
done and you're like yeah bad Birds and
the reaction viewed that in all and he
always says I don't care if you lose he
said this high it goes but he said it's
how you lose on why you lose if you lose
cuz you didn't do your sprints you
should have done your sprints well
because you could have look kid kept
your left hand up and use droppin it he
said now you're just you're taking a
piss if you're gonna lose because you
went and put your heart out he put his
or out and then he got the upper hand
cool that's fine
but I feel like losing always the
feeling of losing the term it depends on
how you lost I've lost fights we have
clearly lost that my first one I've lost
flats that I like this nip and tuck and
your life a little bit more would when
that burns that burns as well but it all
depends in this fact I've lost that
fallout one where I was really convinced
I won and I'm a trouble auxins a bit
dodgy though was on Team GB I mentioned
Lauren softly oh you know II am Amir he
was like how I love is just turned pro
recently he's doing well but surround
yourself with the best Lauren sis yeah
this is it and I remember there's some
decisions like or a change thing for a
couple of them I've had and they're
normally when you travel normally when
you go to tournaments there yeah there's
a few shaky ones
well Irish boxer who Conor McGregor
walked out he he had a right
Macca Quinlan that's what he did a run
on because it's true because they do
they take people's dreams away you know
I remember I was 15 I went to the
European Championships in Russia what my
way would way to the final had a Russian
guy in the final Wow
beat him clearly beat him everyone
watching on the stream I always always
go in my dad's view if he says you won I
he doesn't lie to me I'll bet our cool I
want he texts me said yeah you got that
and I lost my was that Wow really nice
but then it happens and then you learn
to grow with it you learn to get over it
it happen again to me in the Youth
Olympics I was fighting the world number
one he's got a good reputation I beat
him I beat him and today I still believe
I beat him and he got a decision and it
just burns cuz you're like if I won I
would have win then I would have got
this and all about this and they just
take it from let's hope that they've got
good churches it Shannon Briggs yeah if
JJ were to lose this fight obviously
you're not thinking about that no it
wasn't opposed to knowing him as well as
you do now how do you think you would
deal with that family JJ I think he
would immediate the moment of her very
much
hug rebirth up immediate demand of a
rematch and I feel like you'd see a lot
of outside aspects of his life get
ditched okay for a decent amount of time
to avenge wow it feels like I feel like
we're gonna see a rematch regardless
because oh yeah I'm I want to get in the
way of that right really that's my goal
my goal is to make Logan think well I
don't want to read my [__] no rematch
yeah that is the truth when I'm
preparing jr. for this camp I say to him
almost every time I see him there's no
LA show there's no LA flat there's no us
fight you fight him beat him
convincingly enough he says you know
what fair dues
I don't need to
that annoys me I want to go to LA look
Morgan but what we've picked up about
both for the one thing the couple of
things that these lads have got in
common is they're used to being the
winner their big egos yes they want to
dominate and I do feel like regardless I
don't think either of them are gonna
handle it well if who can I say one
thing as well JJ was the only person in
the last fight who had a group of people
waiting to rush the ring if he won yeah
and Joe had and I respect - I think
again he's got a very small circle he's
got his mommy's got his cousins but
they're not the same rambunctious group
of people who were gonna rush a ring
whoever loses in this fight there's
gonna be a lot of people in that ring
afterwards I feel like if Joe would have
won on the ferry deferred there the
arena would have went crazy absolutely
now we have those iconic images of stuff
you mean I thought I feel like in
Manchester it's gonna be even more crazy
because now the crowd bigger arena like
Jay that's really you won't hear
yourself no I I don't I honestly don't
think you hear yourself when JJ wins if
I can if I can reason after how how that
went the last press conference and how
the crowd were I mean that we've been
we've commutated at Wembley in places
like that but being in such a contained
space that volume seemed like magnified
because it was so enclosed and you know
what he want to rock me and I think he's
playing like Drago Crouch oh yeah if I'm
Logan I'm playing like JJ crowd chance
to get because I feel like that is just
like the crowd not gonna be like that
thing is it I feel that's true he should
do it
Joe one thing that stuck out for me from
Joe's documentaries when he said he runs
listening to white noise or you runs
this in to block out the sound and block
out the crowd
and that puzzled me yeah I thought put
some
heavy metal on me yeah he said he's
gonna listen said just to block out the
sound and you know these things are a
factor it's gonna affect Logan whether
it affects him positively or negatively
is entirely up to him and how he
prepares but it's gonna affect him
you're not gonna walk into an arena in a
country that's not yours
with the crowd supporting neither guy
and not be affected you can I've ever
use it to fuel you or you let get in
your head he's coming over
Thiago ya know cause I feel like II I
can feel he has to do it in a way you
know he's coming over as a yes it's too
much he's the guy he's the but he's the
box finger I think he thought he'd go to
Bethnal Green and it would be like oh
happy little English place like actually
and I think he was right I think they
were all fired by the react the thing is
the crowd that were there not you not
the usual crowd that Logan and Jake
appeal to or watch their videos or
anything so I feel like it was like okay
we got rented cars we've come from
samples Cathedral and Buckingham Palace
and we just ended up in the middle of
this this show you who's a very
prestigious venue it is very when you
used to say you box at you a box a on
one occasion my dad box there as well
now a lot of people you want to box at
you'll call I feel like it was named top
ten on one of the the Ring Magazine
which is a big box in magazine I just
want to say you don't want to take a
[__] at your called off
a quick piss before when I was like I'm
not coming back in these nine no it's
not the nicest place what you can't get
a bad seat in then that is why it's such
a good venue if you're in the balcony on
the floor you'll see him what's
happening you're so close to the action
yeah and yeah that's probably why I went
there but yes see in that the crowd
definitely would have got to him and
just a faint there's gonna be thousands
of that in the audience on the night
it's gonna be hard for him to do if he
hasn't dealt with it well so far so
let's see how you do if you're on the
big stage which people are just
different like how to mean it's just
different do you know what I mean okay a
different atmosphere yeah like people
don't like go into football stadiums
think I'm gonna help from you know like
we have a big presence you know little
girls screaming okay we can do it this
like when you come here were dominating
yeah happening you know when teams come
like you said with the football they
come over they go to Anfield and their
hair in the floor people's off yes
serious what was it like going to Russia
because Russia Russia in the first place
in an interesting country yeah know what
obviously they had a great World Cup and
there are lots of lovely people in
Russia but there also some very less
hairy people in Russia Glenn to Russia
was an experience all this stuff makes
me mature I think because I experienced
a lot of stuff traveling I've travelled
a lot for some am age through boxing and
when I went there I was just told to
stay with a team right yeah don't wander
off
don't don't branch off anywhere because
you might not see us again
so you stay with us and it'll be fine so
it was it's intense that is intense and
that plays on your mind you know you're
a kid and you're thinking why didn't
your parents tell you the same thing
before you flatter that listen might be
cool wandering around over here stay
with the team do your thing because not
everyone's gonna like you are there for
multiple reasons well do you react well
to threat like when Logan walks in the
gym to you does your heart rate raised a
little bit or use it on those chill
people
I'm very chilled until you actually do
something to me I'm preachers man did
all you they did highlight something
that you almost did on stage at that
earlier conz because you've kind
yeah yeah yeah I think it crossed your
head like I might slap this guy yeah and
you sort of pull back yeah because it
we've got this Idol pushing and shoving
and they started invading my space you
know everyone's born with this circle of
space yeah and then when you step inside
yeah exactly so they decided to step
into our space and test our ground and
all furry and we just offered a bear
resistance that's all and you clearly
watch the footage I didn't go all out to
try and smash Jake across the face it
was just a little come on come on oh
yeah and it don't need it to do some big
dudes yeah the thing is this is a big
difference in the camps JJ has proper
people in his camp that care about him
regardless would be facts again or not
they have entourage they have a big
entourage
they have pee I know there's definitely
people in their circle that they don't
know that don't even know each other
they just all hired and brought together
and say what we've logan today follow me
20 guys fun of him and that's what
happens there I can guarantee it I know
everyone in act in that entourage
they're all buddies get on and chill
together that is the difference between
Logans camp and JJ's captain we all know
each other what clothes we all talk from
security guard to physio to chef to PT
boxing quote sparring partners everyone
gets on I don't feel like it I don't
know you how do you guys would do for
you get a vibe we're getting honest
yeah you know it was also it was evident
from what we saw in the press conference
in London like there were two I mean
Facebook video makers in his entourage
those people aren't normally there in
Logan sighs I don't know anything about
them I'm sorry to kind of Donna sighs
enough I'm not making a critical
evaluation I'm just saying like they
don't know JJ I don't know how how long
if Charlotte Briggs we don't need we
don't need to go go into it but that's a
perfect on the thing is this what could
do this kinda brings a big guy that's me
he's a big guy never felt small in my
life until I stood next to my [__]
baby
yeah I'm fine Jesus makes him even
bigger wanted Klitschko even more brave
and I'm pouring water at spies what no
you see if you seem fictional you
understand my sizes in this thing yeah
and there yeah he's a different size do
you know anyone like that did you trade
no I don't know I don't know AJ
personally anymore there was a point
where we was in the same camps together
training up in chef food I was a youth
and he was early stage of his pro career
and we used to talk up in the camps and
stuff we never been close enough of him
where's I'm not here to fabricate things
cause lately obviously since the
critical fight his fighting style seems
to have changed slightly to me anyways
more conservative he's he's pretty
careful game opposition's getting hard
yeah well that's what is our positions
getting harder you've been knocked down
you know okay this is its kind of tough
if I go out reckless and not think about
my defense I will get knocked down and
he's realized the dangers now of
heavyweight boxing compared to at the
start of his career and now he has a lot
to lose and I feel like because we see
them get knocked out in the amateurs
like if luck got short yes flat like yes
he can be he knows he can be vulnerable
he's been reminded of his
vulnerabilities and I feel like he's
being very cautious on making sure that
they're not exposed again and it doesn't
open in the end another feat your crews
own cruiserweight here over that
triangle that everyone saw pitting right
now with wilder Joshua Renteria who
would you have come off as king of that
fury is definitely the best boxer I
group had not even Dowie
at all because I feel like he sort of
looms over the other to almost you know
he's just left that Ghost there for
there means like I see like a few fury
is definitely the best box or
technically he's the best boxer I love
the movement he's movement he's got the
most character outside as we was talking
about joining the two he can do that and
he wins it I think he boxes rusher he
beats any boxes
meet Celeste I have fully backed Furion
on a [__] fence [__] well now it's
just fitness so yes I mean it did turn
into her up some fat love [__] for a
minute he did but when he's on Form he's
on for me because go that was a 12 round
about this lean box in there did like a
glove on him really that's the thing I
have and I haven't seen coach Bo lose
that convincingly even though he did
stop him yeah it was a back-and-forth
fight that I think Fury tweeted I said
it on Instagram but it was like you had
the fight of your life he didn't land a
glove on me mate
there's a big difference and it's true
it's true I'm sorry for fury though
because he didn't get the adulation that
I got through Joshua's like gone with
the Golden Boy of England but yeah I
feel like fury did even better job on
them in a way I nobody give a [__]
because it's fury me personally I feel
like sometimes in this country sometimes
over here we don't like people that are
too you know like black dragon and
they're too outspoken we like the humble
characters who are just going with my
day and I just do my job and I'm good at
it
thank you very much thank you very much
they take to that more I feel like in
the States
they like you when I see you I mean and
fury has that personality over here so
now everyone always takes to it but it
does make you want to watch him
absolutely yeah actually in the UK as
well I think he'd like to say he's a
really unusual character JJ sort of has
similar as well in that he is willing to
play a role that using it necessarily he
doesn't mind being the villain he
doesn't mind being the villain like he
like he says certain things I'm like
okay cool I mean that's what makes him
who he is yeah and that's why I he's the
biggest YouTube movie we have because he
just knows what to do at the right times
to get the right attention to get the
right people engaged and credit to him
and he does have done a good job of it
um I see not 12 recently you said you
think could be beat Conor McGregor yes
I'm interested in the why cuz I don't
agree into Russia all right
yeah I know is that the hunger of
McGregor previously in the UFC compared
to now it's not gonna be the same no
matter how much eat you donut how hard
you train no matter how much you tell
yourself and people it's a natural thing
you just got paid a hundred million
dollars to have a boxing match you come
back to the UFC against a guy that's
2500 and all you dreams about is you you
got your you got your wife you got your
kids you got your your you got your high
life you taking time off he's had a few
troubles and whatnot outside of the
Octagon and this guy all he does is sit
down wrestle beers as you've seen him
you know senior and he thinks when he
comes back all deus ex ladies get in you
watch I'm gonna take that he's never
tasted the feet and there's a reason for
it I think could be maybe if he fought
Connor before come at the boxing match
and everything
Connor wins but now there's a different
type of grip that khabib is working
towards not just winning he doesn't want
to just beat Conor McGregor he wants to
take everything that Conor McGregor gets
out he's one of the best to do it that
he wants that he wants at a time Connor
ain't gonna have that same hunger after
achieving what he has told
how do we go and run in the morning when
you go inside
no one is gonna get up and run but could
be gonna he's got that hunger and that
thing so I think skill wise I genuinely
think Connor is the better fighter
because yes khabib it's all wrestling
his stand-up is really mediocre very
media he's quite slow and he leads with
the chin and he sort of he just runs
forward and if so if we get the corner
from before yes who say spice what
miracle years as more of it as before I
think you'll just be too quickly and
you'll catch him coming him off yeah the
thing is I've so I definitely feel like
that's what makes the fact great right
that you don't know who actually we
don't know who will win corner got the
cars could we put the ground game I've
seen fights that Corner's one where he
spent quite a lot of time on the ground
you managed to get off the ground and
win but I don't I think once he hits the
ground this time khabib is known to
could be a good come here he's known to
just swim you into exhaustion and pound
you out can we get a little without
giving them with too much how you see
this fight ending between JJ and Logan
oh no I believe he he stops him with him
for else that is my honest opinion I
feel with him four rounds you will stop
Logan you said before we went on I think
you jaded literally just did the best
sparring of his life in the last Massa
fact he's had a he had a very very very
good sparring session who you know a lot
of people were there long even my dad
was there actually I bought my board my
dad in just to have a look and be a more
experienced version to me what is dr. J
he was very impressed and he's never
impressed so that's good talk about
going pro yeah do you think that that's
pretty mature that can happen I think
pro boxing isn't pro in other sports
like when you're pro in other sports you
are you're gonna be a certain standard
that you can't just dip into I feel like
this is why a lot of people think they
can do boxing because there is drastic
like differences even though they're
both called pros this pro world
chocolate world champion there's a J's
of the world and then there's other guys
that literally drive the cab during the
day I'm gonna fight in the evening if JJ
wants to be a pro he can definitely have
a pro fight
I ain't gonna go and put him in there
against myself or something like that
you know how would you pick the opponent
you didn't using he could get in there
with a pro in and do all this result yes
I think he could be a professional boxer
because I know how a pro boxing is and I
know how the levels work and just
because you've acquired a pro license
doesn't mean your skill as much one of
the things I've been asked to ask you
about more than anything
yeah is what happened with Deji oh yeah
yeah you were trained and edgy for a
period of time yeah can you give us an
idea of what that was like and why you
ended training training Neji was a a new
task for me as a coach it was difficult
because he's a
harder to her than JJ ye possesses of
Billie's he just doesn't pick things up
as quick as JJ but he was you gotta read
you got a go on him a bit more you gonna
be on him a bit more and say catchy go
again go again go again go again and
once you go in there he's he got some
qualities that even JJ didn't possessed
him anyway like his speed power a head
movement natural ability is literally
better than JJ in my opinion like it's
true that when you actually think about
it I was looking him small one time and
I was like he you do things that even
your brother don't do and I haven't even
we haven't really worked on it that much
here because I did see from the early
videos when he was just hitting the deck
very quickly
yeah and then there was a couple of
small videos that came out later on yeah
had some time with him yeah you seen a
drastic improvement from theurgy so what
was the reason why you stopped training
together sort of thing it was all legit
--ax it was the travel it was the fact
he wasn't he's made it publicly known he
wasn't happy yet to say I'm in the house
he wasn't happy with the support he was
receiving outside of Watson training me
and edgy have no personal issues at all
as cool as we were before
obviously I see him less cuz I don't
train him as much but the feeling that
when I was training him and when we went
later press conference to get my mono
we'll see each other as the same good
feelings and good same good vibes it's
just that he wasn't gonna travel all the
way from Peterborough to train with me
when he decided to move back on it feels
like although everything you say makes
sense with their skills that dodgy like
it's naturally very good yeah chick has
maybe even more of a size if I jump to
Daddy that Logan does on JJ like yeah JJ
quite a big lad like he's except with
yeah yeah like when it comes to s fakes
yeah Deji is definitely a discipline he
isn't gonna be he isn't bigger he is my
dog
if Deji it puts his head down and who
has been putting his head down him
grinding as it seems
I put my money on dizzy because I know
their mentality he wants to prove the
world wrong
he's fries of proving people wrong he
doesn't want to be the shadow of anyone
he doesn't want to be just JJ's brother
he wants to show people I am dead G and
if that more of it if he takes that
motivation into his prints into his
smaran when he enters the ring of things
get hot if he if that spirit hits him or
he's like I'm sick and tired of this I
thought I need to prove myself I am
serious and I wanna win he'll be Jay
because I don't believe Jake has that
grit in him - Jake's gonna be more
athletic I think he's gonna have a
natural ability I think if it really
gets gritty and hard in there did she
come win the fight that's a really
interesting insight man could we go back
to the Las Vegas trip because yeah this
was sort of life-changing for you this
trip really we minute we didn't cover it
before but you asked to get in the ring
and spy in front of the mirror whether
trailer yeah yeah yeah so that was a
that was the first time I'd seen you box
by the way oh yeah everyone's seen it I
watching this footage and bearing in
mind like I'd literally just been I
didn't have you Bisping just before then
and I'd watch Bisping in JJ sparring
together or whatever oh yeah yeah and
I'll be watching fightin for like twelve
or twenty years now
and I must admit I was [__] blown
away thanks all right I thought you were
fantastic
the for them how big you are you move
that you're like a [__] cut know
you're fast man yeah yeah he's fastest
[__] this guy for such a big dude I
heard I was watching the campaign sir I
wouldn't have thought twice about
[__] taking you on a minute yeah oh
[__] not I managed to put in a good
performance for myself I feel like go in
there I was JJ's trainer to them I was
just like okay this guy's just full of
it
okay as I mm-hmm I don't know yeah I'm
his coach data okay cool do you put you
in with high-level guys yeah because I
asked a smart buddy jack
he's too a world champion
um and yeah it's crazy but yeah I'll ask
the small with spawn with him and they
were like he's a two-way boy champion
and I know he is
give me some runs they're like nah you
don't need to spar with him but if it
does anyone else around the gym that we
can find you can do some rounds with
them cool to find someone
naughty some smaran and then they found
a guy in and that's the footage that
we've seen in the documentary and we've
seen in JJ's vlog you smashed him
basically yeah I thought I don't know I
needed to do
I put as I say up for good for movements
in I've represented myself well and the
next day I was asked to spar with Andrew
to be who is number four in the world
with one of the top governing bodies
they didn't fill not to do that wasn't
film camera no camera said oh yeah oh I
I don't what I heard I managed to show
that I belong in food and it was crazy
to think okay I'm an amateur boxer I've
come across here I'm sparring with one
of the top guys in the world number one
in the country um my weight class and
I've managed to make him think oh okay
this guy is young and he could be a bit
of a friend the future and I'd done what
I needed to do and off that I've managed
to you know get somewhere so familiar
with us saying yeah so yeah Jeff and
Emir Abdullah who is my manager just my
head coach they decided to offer me a
contract and so it's crazy because Amir
was the guy that said I'm not too smart
buddy Jack and then when I was watching
the documentary by yourself thinking
that guy's my manager now
she had the same manager as a two-way
world champion who he said now you can't
you probably get me to do those no
because now your life your life's being
changed by this whole experience yeah
one of the like a side story to a lot of
people but I kinda can't help but feel
like in 10 years time there'll be
someone watching you on pay-per-view
going that was kiss I think it's a very
unique way of doing things I feel like
it's the first time ever where the
online YouTube community world will care
a lot about actual pro boxing because
they have that link mm-hmm I don't think
it hasn't it hasn't been number four
there's no what there's no there's been
no reason for it to be done
we're a YouTube where the YouTube
community the online community will care
about pro ebooks and as much just
because I was JJ's trained on so it's so
very is it is a pioneering thing when I
think that's crazy I was thinking the
other day when we set this up I was like
you see what Conor McGregor's doing with
the muck life and you see what other
youtube you could build yourself a
massive following by starting up a
YouTube channel and show and everything
that you're doing off of the back of
this and grow your own fan base out of
it so that when you come to sell people
views in the future you've got the fan
base this is this is the thing you say
we've got the I've got the exposure that
a lot of people strive really hard to
get managed to acquire it through a
different angle but numbers as numbers
views have used people of people and now
it's my job to make sure that all of
this talk and all of this positive
praise that I get just ends up being
here you go I fulfilled my duty so that
was gonna be which is a future world
champion how did I feel when you started
after the tree always as you can tell I
try to waste a you know like combat you
know smelling like this cheek to cheek I
didn't know what to do bars night you
know because I believe it's something I
believe it's something that my dad
believes under my close family belief
my friends believe and say hey Altima
cold yeah my goal is to be the best I
can be and fulfill my potential and I've
seen worse people worst boxer than me
become more champions so if I fulfill my
potential
I'll be lucky honestly I do view Tony
bell yoo-hoo I [__] love the guy
he's an absolute warrior but he doesn't
box as well as you do no I'm saying no
no your movement is different
Tony but he's a good fight and he's a
prime example of working with what you
got yeah you might not have movement you
might not have abs you might not have
everything but you work with what you've
got and that's what makes boxing and
exciting sport you got to work with what
you have and that's what makes in the
fairy is that's why it's a world
champion I do think I'm technically a
bear box and Tony baby I would say that
I do I do think that I watch myself and
think okay I'm prettier to watch people
were more likely to watch we don't watch
Tony belly but do they have to give him
the credit raised you know it does they
love the onion and you just can't take
that away from it like you say
personality out of the ring and someone
investing in your story like he's a
classic example of a isn't he yeah
unbelievable
so I'm gonna look through I've got some
other questions from Twitter
SS hope you don't get no funny funny
questions on the first question yes
Twitter is from a person you might know
Kier sighs yeah what was it about the
girl looking for this guy the way
everything you knows how to get everyone
talking then there's no there's no hotel
there's no guilt uh-huh no you must be
difficult though because previously in
this interview of the end every word
you've said it's not
when you do have when you're you're in
great shape
yeah you know you're someone who's not
very prominent you're you know you're
wearing your earrings you feeling good
see that smile
it goes yes it like having all that
attention all of us it's a very
different kind of attention to walk
around Bethnal Green never gonna know
your days are getting [__] it has his
posies yeah yeah this [__] yeah
exactly everything but I was taught from
my mother not to rush these things and
take your time
focus on what you need to focus on and
that's something that just blossoms in
the background your role model who was
the boxer that has inspired you the most
so Ray Jones jr. is my favorite boxer
that is the guy that on a bit too long
he definitely went on a bit too long he
should have retired a long time ago but
he is my favorite boxer me did he fight
car cause he did fight cause I get that
later part of it was felt like he would
have beat Carl soggy if he was proud
hundred percent often has been a better
boxer in their prime then way Jones jr.
is between him and Matt Harrison Matt
Tyson pram and Ray Jones jr. pray Lord
of specifiers else it was my opinion
actually fascinating to see the detailed
and documented where Jay Jay talks about
sitting down and watching Tyson yeah
which is fast I think if you book so you
tractor box my Tyson's one of the first
names that you pop in you you need to
mix everything in that I don't want to
watch one fire and say okay I'm gonna be
like him I want to watch him and say
okay Tyson frozen foot like this and
slips like this original unit does this
even though AJ holds his hands very
correctly he's got good balance I could
take that from him
and that would mean me too oh I'm a fire
that's actually like the Bruce Lee's
attitude wasn't it like yeah a little
bit of everything because why would you
pick one thing if you can pick all who
goes pick a mixer here's the bag with
one bag of sweets same sweet and then
walks off I won't look at you weird yes
true laces that you know I mean Utah
berry lace is just the best you talked
before about how you're now going to
take a following from YouTube or Veda
probox
yeah how do you think pro boxing
audiences are going to view this fight
there's gonna be a bit of rule there's
gonna be a bit of oh you ain't really
done the half of why I've done there's
gonna be a few guys at that there's
gonna be a few guys that are all for it
and saying yeah man do your thing you
know show some the new young because
Logan and JJ but by the time the
pay-per-view numbers are counted oh it's
gonna be crazy I was on the the first
time I said 20 million views I was
pretty close on that I got that yes and
this is gonna be a crazy but with them
with I'm charging for this we don't we
don't know how how YouTube audiences
respond but I they're gonna make good
money these lots and they deserve to as
well because they're they're putting a
lot on the line in terms of physical
health but they also put in a lot time
in terms of reputation and pride as you
said they deserve it because these are
guys are fully capable of making tons of
money doing other things
they can do any other things and make
their putting this event on that's why I
credit to Logan credit to JJ because
they decided to go into deep war hair
and say you know what the only are we
gonna what we're gonna fight
well actually gonna fight for cuz they
could have just sat down and played like
again a fee for some baby to give her a
new year ago
legend the UFC
yeah we'll knock each other oh yeah yeah
fight night
Madden great what is the hardest part of
training Gigi so far for you sometimes I
get cause me and JJ are close so I get
frustrated sometimes if I see him taking
some punches I'm no I'm not I can feel
the punches I'm not you don't need to
take those punches so sometimes I get a
bit emotional by a be honest you know
I'm poker face most of the time but then
when he is taking some punches we get
certain sessions I'm not a pro back yet
you know I get a bit down about a week
both get a bit down about it but then I
feel that's what holds the improvement
so the hardest bit is how close we are
it has his ups and as is dance how much
has JJ improved since the Joella fight
and he's improved tons by the way he's
improved he's improved a lot I feel like
we have a really good base to work with
after that fight you could see how much
she was using his jab which is an
underrated punch and wasn't he was using
it more than lot of body shots which
support but a lot of body shots - I
always said - up and down up and down up
and down we always welcome it up and
down because it it's so easy to hit on
he looks great doesn't he look you take
a big punch cirno's you go oh yeah it
looks great if you've been hit with a
body shot before if you have a body shot
one day will test so that's what that's
why she struck me during this
documentary I know watch the documentary
before and thought wow I want to try
that out but watching you train JJ in
the way that it you instill discipline
in him as someone who wants to put a bit
more discipline into their life at the
moment I think it was something I want
oh you want to almost want to experience
it is I always say to you the other day
I want to get into a cage with a shark
the Sharks outside the cage but you
almost want to be particular time
my self-discipline in a fight the amount
of people like that actually I think
we'll try boxing ain't gonna go that
fast but I might just say you know
Sports Direct so a pair of gloves then
they were heavy bag I'm just gonna pick
that up I might whack it like three
occasions in their life and be a Terran
but it's decent I remember getting
punched by a boolean that the body wants
and just being on that girl and yeah
this was a Charlie wait this is it
no try to wait outside Metro I was bad
my podcast ever and people still message
me and go that story inspires me because
I was being a bully not fizzling didn't
a tree fall on us some tree fell on oh
yeah just say I'm gonna put a tree on
you if you just what a tree falls on
them so that's a problem that moment
when you see a tree fall on someone
you'll never have such please when you
see a tree good your chest not the word
bit with with this store we hope like
because you you know what people like
Tony bother you Tyson few been cannot
say lately knife crimes like ridiculous
right now and like if JJ Morgan can push
kids don't a good road of like yes
that's the thing like we managed of the
Java as you see at the end of the
documentary we've managed to set up a
boxing camp where we get the kids in
they come down they just learn a little
bit just of what JJ was learning for the
Joe fight and continuing to learn for
the low gunfire just getting fitness and
we get people travel around Europe we
have a guy guy came from Hungary twice
to join the camp and just train with us
and this is thinking wow like we
inspired you to leave your country get
on a plane and learn a bit of boxing
that is not and um it these guys don't
realize what they do them because they
live in their world they live in their
world or just doing what they do and
when you leave
out you're when you step out your bubble
you realize I am inspiring this and
inspiring this kid this kid thinks that
he's might be what champion one day he's
gonna try and work to be world champion
one day because he saw JJ beat Logan
2050 got aspirations outside of like not
only do you want to just achieve your
goals but you like the idea of building
a feel like these mentioned boxes going
on for a bit too long I feel like it's
because they don't have many avenues
well I don't have avenues on what they
want to do I feel like they've they
dedicated their whole life to being the
best box that they can be they reap the
accolades and the rewards of it but then
when they look to turn to somewhere out
there there's not much to turn to so
he's hey you know what I'm just gonna
come out of retirement in fact again it
becomes a habit
I hope there's loads of other things I
want to do I'm gonna dip into clothing
I'm gonna do more with the boxing camps
and stuff like that like there's so many
things I want to do like realistically
you don't only get punched in your face
longer than you have to you know I mean
I'm pretty good looking right so last
question how would you like to be
remembered
how would I like to be remembered hmm I
don't to be liked by everyone
I don't ever be remembered as a as lack
of fun everyone because I think you're
fake you know I want to be remembered as
a genuine person I want some people to
remember me as a prick yeah this is the
truth I want some people to remember me
as a prick I want the people I love and
really care for and everyone that
supports me to remember me for what I've
done and what I achieved and personally
I had but then I also want some people
to think then that gives a me because
that keeps conversation but because the
very things positive conversation ends I
think you've got a really balanced view
of the world mate
balance between the good chocolates in
the fight it's gonna be a good one
I was genuinely inspired like people who
haven't bought documentary someone who
makes documentaries or tries to I was
really struck by you as a character in
the documentary and you know we have a
lot of guests on the show that we talk
to I think I took quite a lot away from
the documentary from the stuff that you
said so it was crazy like when I learn
was in the cinema there's people walking
past me tonight you might not know it
but you that documentary was done that
you know it's like Jade this is
life-changing yeah like you that
documentary if you wasn't in it it would
have wouldn't have been half of what it
was an undesirable but that everyone was
really saying that the way the
performance was on-screen and presence
that was there complemented by the story
of JJ makes for massive think it's
actually number one on iTunes now as
well yeah this initial sometimes
talented people will hook up with people
with big numbers and the two of them
benefit ksi versus logon if you haven't
already where commentate and we're gonna
be there we were in the first
documentary I told you I was sitting in
the cinema and I called you immediately
since I left didn't I and I was like so
proud of you what you did in in that
fight the commentary was spectacular
gonna be even better next so anybody
will be in Java and on any races great
yeah hit the like button subscribe fall
over doll on Instagram thanks for
watching we'll see ya